hello and welcome to this video let's
try again
yay I should have stopped after the game
before that was so unbelievably awful on
my end
the opening was played by my opponent by
I don't know
I don't want to insult any anybody with
the 1000 rating but it was roughly like
that and then as to loss
anyway so um we have a toriel opening
here basically playing that just to try
it out I don't really know the details
oh this is normally played I'm a bit
surprised why does he give me the power
push-ups him
it should be quite comfortable
I mean nothing special of this
neighborhood
didn't feel very urgent to give away the
bishop helm
you
you
yeah where do we go with this bishop
yes normally
more promising because I mean they
probably will go five and then rather
want to be on III let's do that
you
you
okay
that has been mysterious
st5 sometimes to smooth that away
productively King age seven is a strange
move what is that about
let's take it
we thought about that
for a moment but okay even it takes like
that and
I wasn't super sure about night cheeks I
mean here should be even quite
substantially better
see for
[Music]
let's see format
that should that could still be okay
actually um
I want to be on this diagonal to make
to keep the pressure on f7 that is some
it's worth something but yeah I'm still
not c5 okay it could be it could be that
he is okay
cannot give up the bishop
with leader Bishop and
- easy
you
you
an all-nighter for please
I doubt that this is actually useful
[Music]
you almost you just have to go back
basically and one of the next moves
which is completely users on age five
yeah now how does he come all this a
five c5
he doesn't that's the clear answer he
doesn't
so I can take a 5mm
Stanny what is swiss go on hand let's
check this night f4 or what is the thing
it can never be enough but it might so
play it
you
there's also never f5m that is then
Bishop on c2 is very useful in
preventing this idea
you
you
you
hmm actually I would go Knight f4 yeah I
mean it's so completely lost if you play
something normal
yeah it's the best move I mean it's not
the best move it is the only move that
um yeah poses problems let's say it
should not be enough but it is at least
some some chance
take take 95 something like that here I
think when g4 should
be quite okay
now
you
it's
what is he threatening
age five I can stop with e5 let's do it
yes nine seconds so
you
no-no-no I ever attack all right yeah it
was a bit odd the way he played it I was
surprised that he simply gave away that
Bishop and it was not really necessary
at this point and German it is
comfortable but comforta opposition from
him King age 7 that was odd 5 now this
is debatable if it actually should take
because the way the center is currently
set up it's not really a threat and that
he takes so I could play what the engine
gives Queenie - it's not a bad idea
maybe going here fornix ok takes one I
was more afraid or concerned and say
afraid is a bit strong about this maybe
try to put some pressure here
no I think this gives black a bit more
counterplay D cake soup D 127
come true went back home and now night
age five that leads nowhere
really something like H 5 H 5 s looks
interesting try to play this
it's a lot better than night age five
the night is just not doing anything and
now things start to start to crack no I
think this is the best chance that it's
a sacrifice I was just thinking Knight
g5 that is giving a bit more hope
Oprah below a little bit I can't do that
but at least I hear you can imagine a
like a check here or something
the engine doesn't see anything but that
store would have been a bit scary for
sure okay guys thanks for watching